- Vendre des canaux, on fait ça
depuis 113 ans dans la famille
de Jean Légaré.
JEAN LÉGARÉ, président-directeur
général, Canot Légaré
- Une pandémie c'est pas le fun,
mais ça a permis de mettre
de l'argent le plein air.
- 2020 a été une année record.
Le même scénario se dessine
pour 2021.
- On a presque vendu
l'équivalent de la dernière
déjà, puis on est au début mai.
- Que ce soit le kayak, le canot
ou la planche à pagaies,
tout part à la vitesse grand V.
MARIE-CLAIRE AUDET-GAGNON
Respo. sécurité, Eau vive Québec
- Ça a été un peu l'explosion.
Autant dans les ventes, que dans
les centres de location,
que sur les lieux de pratique.
- Une popularité propulsée par
la pandémie. Les sportifs sont
contraints de rester au pays.
PIERRE MARQUIS, directeur
général, Canot Kayak Québec
- La masse qui arrive subitement
sur le plan d'eau où on a
souvent peut-être pas
les infrastructures
pour répondre
à cette arrivée massive-là.
- Ce qui provoque une
cohabitation plus difficile
avec les résidents.
- Quand on a préparé
une activité puis qu'on se
rencontre qu'il y a des autos
partout, puis qu'on veut quand
même y aller, il arrive souvent
des comportements qui ne sont
pas du tout adéquats.
Des gens qui sont stationnés
dans des parcs, qui bloquent
les entrées des gens,
des citoyens.
- Et plusieurs de ces nouveaux
adeptes sont des néophytes.
- Conditions météo, le vent,
le courant, la température de
l'eau, on est au printemps,
il ne faut pas sous-estimer
la température de l'eau.
- Une méconnaissance qui a coûté
cher en vies humaines.
RAYNALD HAWKINS, dir. général
Société de sauvetage du Québec
- L'année dernière on avait
95 décès liés à l'eau.
C'est 15 de plus que la moyenne
de 80 qu'on a au cours
des 10 dernières années.
- Selon un rapport
de la division québécoise
de la société de sauvetage,
84 % des noyades ont eu lieu
sur plan d'eau naturelle.
- Il y a plus de noyades
en rivière au Québec que tout
partout ailleurs dans le reste
du Canada. Dans le reste
du Canada, c'est plutôt
le contraire. C'est des lacs.
- Et la moitié d'entre elles
impliquait des embarcations
nautiques.
- Neuf fois sur 10 ne portaient
pas correctement leur veste de
flottaison.
- Des morts qu'une simple veste
aurait pu éviter selon la
société de sauvetage.
Ici Marie-Josée Paquette Comeau,
Radio-Canada, M